if you've watched any number of nature
documentaries you've probably seen some
variation on this scene in place of
ciliates you might see a lion stalking
its prey or a shark lunging for its next
meal the tension builds the motion of
spring-loaded muscles masked by creeping
music as the predator waits for its
moment to strike sometimes the outcome
is similar to this feeding frenzy but
other times the kindly voice of an
elderly narrator assures you that the
prey has escaped all is well this time
the micro cosmos is filled with its own
versions of these tales of predation and
survival this isn't a world built on
nocturnal predators or camouflage that
shields predator and prey alike these
are hunters who have to resort to other
methods to find their food like this
lacrima Riyaz sweeping approach to the
hunt while this protest may look
delicate it is an incredibly successful
hunter it can extend the tip of its neck
out to seven times the length of its
body and then retract it back in a
matter of seconds and it uses this
motion to seek out its prey
each time the lock romário sticks its
head out what it's really doing is
gambling it's playing the odds that as
it whips around it'll make contact with
food and it can play this game for
minutes and minutes using the dense
cilia on its head to search until like
this lucky lack romário an unfortunate
ciliate comes into contact and quickly
becomes prey
[Music]
but not all threats in the micro cosmos
move so quickly
sometimes it's the stationary organisms
you have to look out for
Calathes for example are a type of
rotifer that are sessile meaning they do
not move around instead it attaches its
foot to a surface and just Waits letting
its exceptionally long cilia hang out
like cat's whiskers to draw in food and
from this angle the rotifers seems to
make catching food look easy like it
just needs to sit around and wait for a
flagella to stroll into its mouth from
the flagella its perspective the
situation is a little more dire it was
just casually living its life one second
and then trapped and the belly of a
rotifer the next take a wrong turn in
the micro cosmos and you might find
yourself facing other threats as well
not just at the hands of a predator this
ciliate came from a lake that was nearly
frozen and as we prepared it for the
microscope the organism had to contend
with a very rapid change in temperature
unable to withstand that change in its
surroundings the cilia died its membrane
rupturing and emptying out all of that
order immediately returned to disorder
[Music]
this other ciliate was able to survive
the initial temperature shock that took
its neighbor but as it nears the spilled
contents of the dying ciliate the
healthy one suddenly becomes much less
healthy and it too bursts we've seen
this before on our channel and it still
remains a mystery no matter how many
times we watch an organism experienced
this strange contagious death perhaps
there was a change in osmotic pressure
around the first dying ciliate which
would have then damaged the membrane of
the healthy one wandering by but some
threats can be anticipated this home
alone is a single celled hunter and it
is on the prowl searching for something
delicious to eat in a veritable buffet
of Paramecium and when one potential
prey comes near the home alone lines up
using structures on its ectoplasm called
extrusive that act like harpoons to
pierce their target and inject toxins
into them but where you might expect a
victorious hunter this home alone
recoils back it all happens so quickly
it's hard for us to see exactly what's
going on
it turns out that the homeless owned was
not the only organism coming into battle
armed the Paramecium had its own
defenses to a four micron long structure
called a Trico cyst that can extend to a
longer length in a matter of
milliseconds in response to some kind of
stimulus like another organism trying to
injure it the home of zoom is able to
get its attack and stunning the
Paramecium but it is also left confused
by the paramecium's response as it
begins nibbling away on those protective
Trico cysts instead of the delicious
microbe itself and in the meantime the
Paramecium
is able to recover and escape this time
but sometimes these natural protections
can fail you test eight amoebas form
protection out of bits of sand from
their environment sticking them together
with an adhesive to form a shell it's
difficult for us to get a good image of
this shell but it's that dark shape
moving through the frame and like any
shell it's great protection as long as
you can stay inside it but the amoeba
has things that have to do and that
means it needs to extend its body
outwards using its pseudopodia and in
that moment of vulnerability the
collapse strikes collapse may be tiny
but they have extrusive that pack quite
a punch the toxins they inject into the
amoeba do their work quickly tearing the
pseudo podium apart and like a pack of
scavengers following the smell of blood
in water these coops can sense the dying
amoeba they swarm around and consume the
bits and pieces the undigested amoeba
visible inside their bodies while the
shell sits uselessly next to them but
the micro cosmos is remarkable in its
resiliency and so let us end with this
ciliate which has dealt with some kind
of damage there are a number of microbes
that are able to repair themselves some
of which we've talked about on this
channel but we haven't been able to show
you one in action we don't know what
caused this ciliates membrane to rupture
in this way where we can see these bits
and pieces almost poking out of it but
as it turns and turns and waves its
cilia we can see its membrane beginning
to knit back together until finally at
the end it almost seems as if there was
never any damage to begin with the
ciliate has survived this day
and all as well no matter what may
happen tomorrow
you
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and if you like what
we do you should be thanking these
people on the screen right now they are
our patrons on patreon I know there are
some of you right now looking at your
own name
so thank you and if you want to join
that wonderful group of people you can
do that at patreon.com slash journey to
micro if you want to see more from our
master of microscopes James check out
Jam and germs on Instagram and if you
want to see more from us you can find
our channel at youtube.com slash micro
cosmos
[Music]
you